-I started last "Corrections"
saying,
"Last 'Corrections' in March."
And a lot of you pointed out
when you saw it,
it was actually April 1st.
Gotcha.
[ Light laughter ]
Brontosaurus --
So this is interesting.
I said dinosaurs --
I was talking about dinosaurs,
said brontosaurus,
said pterodactyl.
A lot of feedback
from those of you in the know
re: dinosaurs.
Brontosaurus,
it's apatosaurus, I guess,
is the correct name
for what we --
When we see a brontosaurus,
it's actually an apatosaurus.
But then in 2015, they did say
brontosaurus was okay.
So I think I'm in the clear.
Pterodactyls
also are not dinosaurs.
They're pterosaurs.
I feel like in 2015,
when they were doing
all this reclassification,
though, they might have said
about pterodactyls --
The scientists could have
gotten together and said,
"Do we need the P?"
[ Laughter ]
What are -- Who are we
trying to impress?
We had a sketch with a crossbow
this week,
and we mentioned...
that it shot an arrow.
Crossbows do not shoot arrows.
They shoot bolts or quarrels.
And it was very surprising
that we had an error
because that was a sketch that
our writer Ben Warheit wrote.
It's very uncommon for there
to be an error...
in his sketches.
He has a nickname in the
writers' room -- "Kid Details."
[ Laughter ]
Well...
I mean, the worst
of the corrections
are the ones that,
you know, recur.
And once again, I said "less"
when I should have said "fewer."
And I got to say,
this is the heartbreaking thing.
It was in "Corrections"
last week,
and I'm gonna play it for you.
Watch in real time
as I catch myself,
and I'm so worried
I'm doing it wrong,
I correct myself incorrectly.
I get it wrong.
Watch.
Here it is last week,
me saying it wrong.
I also was told I did...
two less "Guess who's backs."
I mean, it just -- the fact that
you've told me so many times
and in the moment...
I get it wrong again...
I think really proves that
this whole endeavor is folly.
I was talking about
"Without Me,"
the classic Eminem track.
And I fell into the jackal trap.
I jackal'd the lyrics
to that song a little ba--
a little bit, excuse me,
about the fact that
I've always found it confusing
that the song starts,
"Guess who's back.
Back again. Shady's back.
Tell a friend.
Guess who's back, guess who's
back, guess who's back."
And I'm saying, "Why do you
keep asking us who's back,
to guess who's back, no less,
when you told us?"
And then people said that,
"You're not listening
to 'tell a friend.'"
Those are then the friends
passing on "Guess who's back."
And...I'm embarrassed
and I'm ashamed.
I'm embarrassed I got it wrong,
and I'm ashamed because
I think the reason I did that,
the reason I was nitpicky
is I...
hold a grudge, a small grudge,
with Eminem.
[ Light laughter ]
I am a huge fan of Eminem.
To the point that I wrote him
a couple of letters.
[ Laughter ]
Never heard back.
Six months I waited.
He got them.
I wrote the address perfect.
I don't want to defend Eminem's
titular character, Stan,
but I will say,
at least he took the time
to air his grievances
via letter,
unlike you, who just type it
into a comments section.
Be so ni--
One of you take the time...
to write a nice letter.
You're just firing it off,
often with worse grammar than
the grammar you claim I'm using.
Unpopular opinion,
"Stan" is the best
of the epistolary raps.
I will say, I can't believe I'm
going to do this right around,
turn around and criticize
another Eminem lyric choice.
But in the end --
the last verse of "Stan,"
so are we to expect --
So Eminem's writing
the letter to Stan.
And then we hear
a pencil scratching.
In real time, he figures out
this is the Stan
he just saw on the news.
And he writes, "Oh, wait.
That was you. Damn."
Are we -- So in the Eminem
rap-o-matic universe,
is the idea that he --
at Stan's house,
there's an unopened letter
that Eminem finished, "Damn,"
and then signed?
These are the answers
I'm looking for.
We said only a lunatic
would drink Diet Dr Pepper,
and...
two things we got in
the comments section this week
are dinosaur experts
and Diet Dr Pepper drinkers.
'Cause a lot of you said
it's a wonderful drink.
And no hard feelings.
I do want to prove
that it was just a joke
and we did not mean any --
[ Laughter ]
We were --
It was in reference...
...to...
to Sarah Palin.
And...
we...
[ Laughter ]
Every time Sarah Palin comes up
in the news, I --
it makes me reflect on...
a very special time
for me at "SNL."
Shoemaker and I were there,
2008.
It was a really cool time
to be there,
really cool group
of cast and writers.
And I wrote a sketch
for Amy and Tina
where they played Sarah Palin
and Hillary Clinton.
But, as with all political
sketches at the time,
we were always looking for
other people to pitch jokes.
And if there is a most famous
line in that sketch,
it is, "I can see Russia
from my house."
And I did not --
Shoemaker was the one
who pitched it.
I remember
like it was yesterday.
We were sitting
with the "Update" group,
and Shoemaker said --
he pitched that line.
And then I wrote it.
I wrote it down right away.
So I wrote -- I wrote it.
He said it, I wrote it.
But that is --
It does speak to, for as...
irascible and unpleasant
he is to be around,
Shoemaker is a great producer
because he makes everything
a little bit better.
And that's a perfect example,
because that was
the best line in the sketch
and it came from Shoemaker.
He's been dining out
on it, though.
[ Laughter ]
Not a day goes by.
And the most embarrassing
thing is he still...
[ Sighs ]
He still pitches versions of it
all the time.
Like, it was perfect for that.
But, like, yesterday,
we're writing "A Closer Look"
about Matt Gaetz,
and Shoemaker's just lying
on a couch still.
I think he's fine,
but he's like, "Oh, my hip.
I need the whole couch."
So, like, everybody --
other writers are standing,
and he goes,
"What if Matt Gaetz says,
'You know what I can see
from my house? Russia.'"
What?
[ Light laughter ]
Just the worst joke.
Someone told me a martini
with vodka is called a Gibson.
That's incorrect.
Not to correct a jackal.
It's a -- A Gibson is a martini
with a pickled onion.
It's the nighttime drink
of Diet Dr Pepper drinkers.
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned the film
"The Ice Storm,"
I think this week.
And a wonderful film,
directed by Ang Lee,
an incredible cast.
And one member of the cast
I left out was Elijah Wood,
who, as always in everything,
was so great in that.
And a lot of people said --
accused me, even,
of leaving him out
because he's also in
"The Lord of the Rings" films.
And obviously, I have
a complicated relationship
with those films.
The complication is,
I have stuff to do.
So when I watch a movie,
it's like...
"Pick up the pace.
There's a life outside this."
But that's not why
I left him out.
Alright, so I'm gonna give
a spoiler to "The Ice Storm."
So if you haven't seen it,
pause it, watch it now,
or maybe just skip ahead,
let's say, two minutes.
Elijah Wood's character
dies in "The Ice Storm."
And that's fascinating
because he plays Frodo, right?
Makes it through a trilogy
and then one more movie
as Frodo, lives.
And that's the problem.
There's just no stakes
in "Lord of the Rings."
Like, to make it through
Middle Earth but not...
New Canaan, Connecticut.
[ Laughter ]
Like, nobody dies in
"Lord of the Rings," right?
I know I'm going to hear it.
I mean, Gandalf does, but then
he, like, comes right back.
As, like, Gandalf the White.
Am I supposed to be sad?
He just came back
with a different shirt.
It's like coming home.
"Dad's dead."
"What?"
"Oh, he got a new sweater."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I guess I was sad
when Sméagol died.
[ Deep voice ]
No, you weren't.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Oh, the letters don't turn
on "Wheel of Fortune" anymore.
They're screens.
I should have known that,
but I haven't been home sick
for a while.
I think we have our winning mug.
We got to our final two,
and I think they match up well.
We could have gone
with these two,
but I think these are
our two mugs, right?
We got this on one side --
"Late Night
with Correction Jackals,"
and then we have that jackal
at a computer.
So I think this is --
we're going to try to get this
for sale at the store,
hopefully you all --
And also, Tara told me
that when we first showed this,
a lot of you thought it looked
more like a hyena than a jackal.
And I like that it
makes you unhappy.
[ Laughter ]
Asterisk.
I said it wrong last week,
and the way I pronounced it
definitely was incorrect.
But a lot -- There's this thing
where you accuse me
of doing something on purpose.
It was not on purpose.
It wasn't to set up...some bit.
I just said "asterisk" wrong.
I just flubbed it.
I pronounced it asta--
[ "Never Gonna Give You Up"
plays ]
♪♪
Astley-rick.
[ Laughter ]
I mentioned my book, which I...
I guess at this point
I'm bragging about a little bit.
First book -- First children's
book ever to have...
a bear and a rabbit.
A lot of people
keep saying that's wrong.
And somebody sent me this
and said, "What about this?"
This is from a movie, bro.
It's not from a book.
Then I do weekend "Today" show
with Willie Geist,
our friend Willie Geist.
And they have great researchers.
And I'm watching.
And look at this.
Can you guys read that?
"'I'm Not Scared, You're Scared'
is first children's book."
[ Laughter ]
I mean, I just assumed.
Because it seems like
such an obvious idea.
But, I mean,
I guess all the best --
That's what the best ideas are,
right?
You hear them
and you're like, "Ohh."
That's quite an honor.
I have been reading reviews
of the book.
And mostly positive,
but you go on Goodreads,
and someone gave it
three stars out of five
and said it was cute but wordy,
and I get it.
Not all parents want their kids
to learn all the words.
There's twists, though.
Like, this book --
There's a story.
Like, it's wordy because there
are things that happen.
There's more plot, I think,
than you would find
in a normal kids' book,
and I'm happy about it.
The bear learns
to confront fear,
and you find out at the end
that the whole time the rabbit
has been Russian-born
German heiress Anna Delvey.
And I think the best moment
in the book
is when she says to Bear [As
Delvey] "Do you know who I am?"
I've been trying to get my Anna
Delvey impression into the show,
and I feel like
the window's closing,
and I didn't ever want it
to seem forced.
And I thought
that was pretty organic.
[ As Delvey ]
I'll get your money, Bear.
[ Laughter ]
The European banks are closed.
The -- Oh, we have another...
[ Laughter ]
We have another E.B. White
letter to share.
[ Light laughter ]
Ah.
Another E.B. White letter.
This is really exciting.
Also, I heard from
a lot of archivists --
"archive-ists?" --
that I did a lot wrong last week
when I took out the letter.
You're supposed to use cotton
gloves, if any gloves at all.
They say it's maybe better
not to use gloves.
You just have to have clean,
sterilized hands
because you actually want
the tactile feeling
with an old letter
to make sure --
sometimes when you get gloves,
you'll maybe be
a little rough with it.
So clean, sterilized hands
and then don't use tweezers
because that could
damage the paper.
Certainly don't use tweezers
on the gloves
because that could put
a hole in them.
Don't blow in the gloves
because that gets, like --
That puts the germs inside.
I did a lot wrong.
But we keep hearing from this,
you know, the little girl, Kay,
who wrote the original letter to
E.B. White
saying she didn't like
the ending,
and then he wrote back to her
and said
that he did like the ending.
And her son has reached
out very kindly
and shared these letters
with us.
And so this is a trip.
I believe the original letters
were in 1953.
So now it's 13 years later.
It's 1966.
And Kay Berthold, who is...
now 13 years older --
She reads an article
in "The New York Times" --
this is real -- about --
and by the way,
when I say "this is real,"
everything's real.
It's a tic.
So there was an article
in "The New York Times"
about how librarians had said
"Stuart Little"
was bad for children.
And so he sent us, again,
this is a copy of the letter
that his mom,
Kay Berthold, wrote in 1966
and basically,
"I was very interested to read
your article
about 'Stuart Little'
in the Sunday "New York Times"
on March 6th, 1966, entitled
'Librarians Said
It Was Bad for Children.'
I was one of those children
who expressed dislike
for the book's ending.
When I read 'Stuart Little'
about age 10,
I loved it and yet
was troubled by the ending.
You answered my letter
saying that it was important
not that Stuart found Margalo,
but that he was headed
in the right direction.
Now, 13 years later,
I'm a Peace Corps volunteer
in Uruguay.
'Stuart Little' is still
one of my favorite books,
but more important is the letter
you sent me as a child.
I was thrilled.
Now I say thank you.
So that is the letter that
his mom sent to Stuart Little,
and once again --
not to Stuart Little,
to E.B. White.
Excuse me.
Once again, E.B. White --
what a lovely man
who writes back.
So here is the letter --
you see, on "New Yorker"
letterhead --
and it says,
"Dear Miss Berthold,
it was very good of you
to write,
and I'm glad the 'Times' piece
interested you.
I still receive letters
of complaint from children
about the book's ending,
and I'm sure I always will.
So it was an extra pleasure
to have your retrospective
report.
From your address, I should say
you were headed
in the right direction.
I hope the going isn't too rough
and that the rewards are great.
Along with about
180 million others,
I send thanks and good wishes.
Sincerely, E.B. White."
And it made me feel bad
because obviously, you know,
we've had some laughs
at the expense of Mr. White,
who wrote these beautiful
children's books,
and the fact
that he would write back
to her twice is really special,
13 years later.
But then I wanted to get
the original, right?
So I call my friends at
the Cornell University Library,
and they're like,
"That's not a real letter."
They said this is --
this isn't real.
And they go,
"But we have a real --
we have the real response."
So...
we've got it right here.
And...
Cotton -- cotton gloves.
Get it right this time
because I heard from my friends,
but then do you remember
what I said?
We don't wear gloves
because we want the tactile
feeling of no gloves.
So we take them off.
[ Laughter ]
And then we -- we sterilize
our hands with,
I guess, some sort of alcohol.
This will work.
[ Laughter ]
There we go. That should do it.
And now this is
the actual letter
from E.B. White.
Okay, see,
this is very clearly --
because it has the letterhead,
and there's some fire damage,
which means it's old.
[ Laughter ]
And it's -- you can also tell
it's been in some tea.
So it says, "Dear Miss Berthold,
it was very good of you
to write,
and I'm glad the 'Times' piece
interested you.
I still receive letters
of complaint from children
about the book's ending" --
so it starts the same.
"One particularly bothersome
girl wrote me in 1953 to say,
"I didn't like the ending
because
I don't know if he's going to
get there or not."
Come to think of it,
her name was --
It was you. Damn."
[ Laughter ]
Um...
I want to clear
one last thing up.
I talked about Jimmy Reilly...
last week,
who I asked Shoemaker --
I said, "What is his title?"
And I was told head carpenter,
which is not what Jimmy
has ever told me.
[ Laughter ]
But I guess the show wouldn't
put
"Head mother [bleep] in charge"
in the credits.
[ Laughter ]
And I joked about how you can't
run afoul of Jimmy
or the Reilly family
because they're this
secret cabal that, you know,
run 30 Rock
and pull the levers of power.
Look, I was joking, okay?
I'm --
This is my show, okay?
For all the jokes about
Shoemaker is in charge
or, you know
this person is in charge,
I'm in charge, okay?
I run the ship here.
I'm not afraid
of the Reilly family.
[ Laughter ]
Well, that...
Can they do that, though?
Is it...
Well, isn't...
Well, can anybody else do it?
But isn't that Kathleen?
[ Cellphone ringing ]
Hello?
Well, I was -- I was kidding.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, well, we're just in
the middle of it, and it's...
No, I-I -- no.
I didn't even think
you were here today.
No, I -- It was just a joke.
I don't...
Okay.
Well, can you turn them back on?
Well, I am -- I am going to
think about what I did.
[ Laughter ]
Do you want me to take
the whole hiatus?
No.
The whole thing?
All right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Exhales shakily ]
[ Belches loudly ]